Here's half of my array. I'll just pick up parts for the second half so I can
tell them apart. Here's the other half of my array. Now what could I do? It
looks like it would be helpful if I could swap these two elements, cause that
way I would get this element in place, and also this one. Let's do it again,
that's good. Now these two elements are in place. And so are these. Another
swap, and another, and another, and presto! I'm done. I have what used to be
the second half now in the first half, what used to be in the first half now in
the second half, in exactly the right order. Well that's great, now I can start
writing pseudocode. So which elements did I swap? The one in positions zero and
five. 1 and 6, 2 and 7, 3 and 8, 4 and 9. So each time I swapped position i
with position i plus 5. What's five? That's the length of each sub-array, or
one half the length of the original array. So i started at zero. We'll figure
out in a minute how far it went, and then I'll swap the element at position i
with, well I can't say i plus 5 in the pseudo-code, because the pseudo-code
needs to explain the general situation. So, it was length over 2, now, how far
does i go? In this case, it went from zero to four. So in general, it'll go to
length over 2 minus 1. Now that was the hard part, the easy part is to program
that in Java, and I'll leave that to you.